les organismes ont souffert pour cette
reprise mais les sourires étaient sur
toutes les lèvres après plusieurs mois
d'attentes l'union athlétique de
versailles a organisé ce mercredi 1er
juillet l'un des tout premiers meetings
d'athlétisme en france post confinement
au total 200 sportifs venu des yvelines
et de la région ont répondu présent
retour à l'appui ces normes s'écoule
premier 110 de toute la saison
ça pique ça fait un peu mal au genou
mais le retour à la pisse énorme je
trouve ça fait du bien ça fait du bien
de reprendre les compétitions parce que
on avait repris les entraînement nez
l'esprit de compétition
ça me manquait un peu l'esprit de
compétition ovation et où il ya du monde
et plus et on voit le résultat de les
entraîner l'entraînement le rendez-vous
a été validé à la toute dernière minute
par les instances l'autorisation finale
a été donné à 13 heures le jour même les
organisateurs ont dû répondre au
contexte sanitaire du moment fallait
respecter les gestes barrière avoir les
autorisations de la préfecture de la
ville de versailles de la direction
départementale de la cohésion sociale
donc ça a été un véritable parcours en a
limité le meeting à 200 personnes
environ pour éviter qu'il y ait trop de
monde sur le stade et en respectant à
tout un parcours pour rentrer sur le
stade et sortir du stade le club
d'athlétisme espère maintenant pouvoir
organiser d'autres meetings d'ici la fin
de l'année 2020 une compétition de lance
est notamment à l'étude